is Crocodile Hunter Steve Irwin's  daughter bindi about to tie it to the  night know the dancing champ is only  just shy of 18 still kind of young  however there is a report of a wedding  so is it true you have a show baby can I  have your obey yay my stuff thank you  who can refuse a guy who'd give you his  only strawberry 19 year old wakeboarding  champ  Chandler Powell has been part of Indies  world for the last year she turns 18 on  July 24th and a new report claims the  couple is eyeing September 4th the tenth  anniversary of her dad's death as a  wedding date he's always there for me  and he always makes me smile and laugh  and it's brilliant to have someone so  kind who really understands your world  we checked with a bindi source and while  the couple is going strong they say  there's no truth to reports she's  preparing to walk down the aisle